sometimes you find yourself in the
middle of nowhere and that's where you
find yourself if that makes any sense
mad at me this episode is brought to you
by gray block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles and
it's a special Italian it's a place we
can get Italian pies and different types
of Italian Italian REE so if you know if
you look around your life and you're
Greek or you're Jewish you're you know
Sweden or something like that or you're
you know Tahitian or whatever then you
can change that up in a second by
stopping at 1811 Pico Boulevard and
filling your mouth with some of that
swaggy Italian great block pizza get
that hitter this episode brought to you
also by um this company called Ridge
wallet and Ridge wallet it's that you
know it's that fancy front lump people
want that baby back you know people who
they want that little baby back hump you
know that old-school wallet you know you
put it in your back pocket and it just
rides your butt you know next thing you
know four years later you're sitting all
lopsided you know what I'm saying you
can't even uh you know you have to put
it on a little piece of wood plank under
your other butchy even make yourself
even so you can comfortably digest your
food because your body is so lopsided
from not having the correct posture and
everything you need to eat correctly
because you've been having that rear
bunt hump that butt hump that rear
wallet well change it up now get that
front pocket carry the ridge wallet it's
it's it's practical it's easy and I use
it and honestly I like it and it also
it's bulletproof so if somebody shooting
at you I mean it's really some it's not
very big so you can be hard to block a
bullet but if you can line it up with
the bullet then you'll be able to maybe
stop that bullet Ridge wallet comm slash
Theo for 10% off your order Ridge wallet
comm slash Theo I'm out here in the
middle of nowhere man but
suddenly I'm right here with you guys
and I feel like I know exactly where I
am
I'm not lost anymore you feel me
suddenly I'm just I'm just found you
know
[Music]
she was hotter than the blacktop broke
down at a truck stop she looked about as
wild as the story she told
[Music]
says she was a Christian saving souls
and Susanna and the Senate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
higher than a junkie drying out in
Savannah Lord I hope I don't die in
Alabama thank you guys for being here it
is man it's it's summer look I'm coming
at you from I've been in rural Illinois
all weekend in a town called Wyoming
Illinois and it's the second year in a
row that we've come out here and done uh
some stand-up doing the jokes and doing
the joy you know and uh man I was let me
tell you this last year we came and most
of the townspeople came in this is a
small town you know I'm saying this is a
small town where if somebody farts
across town and you don't if you're not
there to hear it a few hours later
somebody will just tap you on the
shoulder when you over at the gas
station you'd be like well you heard
what happened and you're like what
you're like well Lawrence you know heat
boarding it so it's that kind of place
you can't even fart without somebody
telling somebody else about it you know
you'll hear people just you know
re-enacting other people's farts around
town just because it's that kind of
place you know what I'm saying if
somebody uh if somebody sneezes upwind
of you even if it's a mile away then you
you know you'll hear somebody uh you'll
hear a gesundheit down the hill it's
that kind of place where you know
everything's just everything's connected
it's all there's you know there's
everything is just everything's
connected man like you'll even see um
you'll see birds and they look like
they've been there awhile like in Los
Angeles I see a bird and it's like ah
this [ __ ] just passing through you
know he's just flying around and maybe
you know [ __ ] a little and stuff
like that and copping a little bit of
seed and maybe you know trying to [ __ ] a
falcon or something down by the beach
but after that he's gonna jet town but
you're out here and you know I mean he's
in this route in these rural areas you
know and it seems like and you see a
bird and you're like oh that okay this
his area
you notice his block around here you
know maybe he's a parent or a granddaddy
you know I saw a sparrow look like he
probably had a couple stepchildren but
you know everything has more of a story
because everything has more of a has
more room to have a story you know I
think about that stuff sometimes like in
a smaller town it's uh you know I don't
know I just get so dialed in I get so
dialed in and I just everything just
feels like it's a if you're driving past
a park in a small town the toys in the
park and the swings and the slide they
suddenly they stand out like they have
room to breathe they they mean something
you know they hold memories of people's
pasts and of you know of of children in
the springtime or you know on a fall day
when the you know school got out early
and the kids hit the park you know it's
just or the swing set it might be like
oh you know you may be you you know it's
it's that swing set holds memories of
like a you know a boy you know first
time he swang next to a girl cuz you
remember that I don't if you remember
that I remember being an elementary
school and I was in elementary school
you know some kids didn't go to school
at all I mean I they had a boy in our
town didn't go to school at all and
people thought he was deaf and he just
didn't know anything so I don't know
what ever happened to him do probably
honestly could have gotten hit by a car
because if you don't know about school
man you easily you know could not know
how streets work or could not know how
basic uh you know how to deal with
automobile eree when it's you know
passing by but anyhow yeah and I
remember the first time I you know like
I would swing on a swing set next to a
girl like my whole my whole body the
side of my body next to the girl was
just like just let just almost
rigor mortis had set in
you know just rigor mortis my whole body
just like all the blood was over there
just like listening for her
heartbeat you know my whole that side of
my body was just so heavy you know the
the swing she was closest to next to me
suddenly like the other side of my body
is just gone bleached white and there
and that other side of my body of the
where she was all the blood had run over
there I was just listening to just
trying to get as close to this you know
young lass as I could you know cuz I was
feeling you know it's just what I was
feeling I mean I was just feeling alive
and I think that uh that that's what you
see whenever you're in a smaller town
things just stand out more you know like
and things have more room to breathe you
see a tree and you're like oh that tree
you know somebody has a story that goes
with it or my grandfather and I used to
sit under there and you know we used to
read or think about stuff or you know my
uncle used to hide behind there and you
know your gum or whatever he wanted to
do drink lemonade or something like that
or just you know make homemade tires or
whatever he wanted to do comb his hair
you know put motor oil in his hair and
comb his hair and wear [ __ ] tight
shirts you know and put [ __ ] sand you
know put sand that you know put sand in
his shoes and just pretend it was at the
beach I mean everybody you know but I
just feel like in a small town you get
more stories you know you get more I
don't know things just have more room
and I feel like that man I've went again
when I'm in the cities when I'm in some
of the city I just you feel a little bit
more you ever put a file in a zip drive
you ever do that if you're emailing
somebody you'd send them a group of
files at once but you can zip drive it
and it's the same information it's just
like air sealed kind of it's like
compact that's how I feel when I'm in
the city there's just no room for even
sometimes for my imagination to reach
its arms out of my brain and just you
know pet the world and that's one and
that's something that drives me crazy
sometimes and I feel like I'm not gonna
get that I'm not gonna get that space
I'm not gonna get any of that brain you
know I'm never gonna have that again and
then I come to a town like I did this
weekend / - you're here to Wyoming
Illinois
and man this place 1600 people and I
came here last year and and Itzel you
know the town could probably use a
little bit of diversity here and there
you know it's definitely a little bit uh
you know it's it's it's it's got a
little bit it's definitely got some
old-school white in it but it's good
people you know I mean most of the
people are just friendly you know just
loving people you know you see a lot of
people up here that raise foster
children and do that sort of thing you
know a lot of people are you know have
Church as part of their lives a religion
of some sort you know it could be
whatever their religion is but I think
in smaller towns is just more it feels
like there's more room for anything and
and I had a good time man it was nice
just to you know suddenly just feel
human cuz in Los Angeles things can get
so unhuman and look I mean look I love
it look I have a lot of great friends in
lausanne just saying there's so much
going on it's almost like time and
mother nature and life cannot keep it
all organized and and when you're in LA
it feels like the world is just kind of
juggling a million things at once and
when you're out here I feel like the
world has just like kind of set the
balls down on the ground
and and the balls can rest they don't
have to be flying around in the air
anymore so it's just nice man it's nice
to be a part of it and it's nice to get
into a place and feel like I'm okay in
these places you know driving past
cornfields and reminding me when I used
to you know plant corn and cotton and
you know seeing um you know driving by a
fair you know drove by like a small town
one of those carnivals you know those
shady carnivals come to town and it's
usually a lot of alcoholics and people
and you know different types of type of
methamphetamines and uh people you know
hopped up on uppers basically trying to
keep goldfish alive traveling from town
to town and you see one of those go on
and just reminded me a time I used to be
out there
you know trying to touch a little bit of
titty or vomit behind a super slide just
things I don't know maybe just because
I'm from a smaller place I see a smaller
place and it reminds me but it's also
nice to know that I don't feel
disconnected from those places you know
I don't and that's something I worry
about a lot of times like about how how
how how I change or how I can change
from living in a city or living in one
place you know and how you become more
accustomed to things because as humans
man we become accustom so easily it's
like people always say don't forget
where you came from you don't forget
where you go where you come from but you
get used to feeling like where you are
you know it's amazing how adaptable we
are and how I bet you can go you can go
forward and backward and that's you know
it life's exciting like that you know
hey we got a crazy week coming we got
Jordan Pederson coming in a lot of
people are really excited about that and
I'm grateful you know he's coming in
this week and he's a premier thinker you
know I was just talking with my buddy
Simon Rex about him and in he kind of he
if you're not familiar with him you know
you can check out Jordan Peterson he's a
speaker he's a brain he's a mouth he's a
orator he's a thinker he's a philosopher
and and he's a professor in in Canada
but you know I think he almost he has
this voice that embody that like I don't
know a lot of men from my generation for
like it almost seems like they were
fatherless or they did they weren't
getting the fatherly advice that they
needed and I feel like it's a lot of
those men that go towards him right now
and are listening to him it's like you
know even though he's Canadian he's like
America's number one you know number two
step daddy you know I know Simon Rex
likes to say he's the number one but
anyhow man I've had a good time this
weekend you know so many people came out
to the show in Wyoming last year when I
was there and it's a fundraiser show my
mother grew up in this small town assaut
we do fundraiser to keep the theater and
the history that in the arts department
alive here in this town and amazed you
know last year a lot of the locals
bought tickets and this year people came
from everywhere you know we had a
father-son they said they were
father-son I thought there might have
been up to something you know a little
better a tad our kayaks but they said
that they had the same blood and each
one of their bodies so they came out
people drove him from st. Louis
Wisconsin Chicago I mean I would say 85%
of the tickets were bought not from
people in the town so it was just
incredible you know we all kind of some
dudes showed up a couple of young bucks
he's fellows from Chicago
they weighed that up they were outside
of the theater trying to get it uber at
the end of the night and I'll tell you
this there's no rubriz I mean this is an
area we still have to hitchhike you know
I'm saying that rubra that's you got one
Hoover on each hand daddy
that's that thumb you got to use that
you know that beautiful thumb ship and
and these fellows were out there they're
like yeah we got uh we got water and we
got trail mix we'll be fine my good luck
dude you guys probably gonna get
accosted or molested but sometimes that
happens you know and sometimes that
makes you feel right at home if you get
you know somebody that you don't know
but with you know seem to have a big
heart kind of sneaks up in jerk you off
that can't you know that I can make you
feel kind of you know part of part of an
area yeah I had fun just you know my
brother brought a bunch of crawfish up
here from Louisiana and and so we did a
crawfish boil up here so people could be
a part of that and so it's been a
peaceful weekend I got to see my nephews
and my niece and just spend time with my
family and people that I love and so you
know in people that we haven't always
had that kept that family closeness so
as it comes into my life now I have to I
have to show up for it I mean there's
times where I want to not get again of
not you know take it he take the nap
take it what I got to show up I just got
to be there with my eyes open and my
heart open and just hope to catch some
little pieces of love
that are floating around when people get
together and that's another thing in
these smaller towns when people did I
didn't realize this like without the L
like they only get 4G on their phones
like my phone has had 4G for the past
three days okay so it's really hard to
you're not using you're not watching a
ton of selling your phone because you
can't do it it doesn't even work so
you're just like [ __ ] all that you know
and you just spend time with who you're
around and and that's not as easy to do
in a city you know so it's just you know
suddenly so I get a little bit more of
an inkling of just myself and I start
getting just uh just more ideas pop into
my head you know I get an idea I go
where's that been but if I get so much
influence and I'm then it's less ideas
you know because you know an idea it's
just influence from inside of yourself
but you know we get so influenced from
the outside these days that it's like
ideas are liked and they've been run out
of town so it was you know I found
myself getting a few more ideas because
I just adapt so quick you know you know
you take away one thing and your brain
will get back pretty quickly I believe
even though I worry we get trapped in
this hole in this wormhole these days
with the technology but and that song on
the way in that was a alabama by bishop
gun you guys know that that band but
alabama by bishop gun will have the link
to them below if you have calls for
jordan Peterson make sure to get them in
into the hotline ninety five six six
four nine five zero three and you can
always leave calls for any of our guests
there are on the the fan line and the
fan line is we can leave video questions
for our guests and and that that link is
on the YouTube page also make sure to
subscribe to the podcast you know we
need subscribers we could use any
support as well if you have a product
that you feel like would be dope that
you want to advertise on the prop on the
podcast you know hit us with an email
there's a
email on the website on theof on comm
what else man I've just been I'm just
trying to navigate this industry you
know this Hollywood is a sneaky industry
you know it's a cine key it's a sneaky
industry and I'm just trying to navigate
it as well as I can and it's tough man
and it's tough you know
but I'm grateful I'm realizing more and
more that some of the acquaintances that
I have around me that they want that
they just want to make good stuff and
and and a lot of it sometimes it's just
me I just have to trust you know so much
I sometimes I want to be so
individualistic sometimes that it's not
it's not even might not even be to my
benefit sometimes you know that I just
need to learn to be more trusting and to
know that that more I've noticed one
thing more things get done when I don't
try to do things alone
man for so long in my life I was like I
got to do this [ __ ] alone I got to do
Nami mag I can handle it okay good let's
are gonna handle it you know I could
handle it Susan even on even Noah Susan
and I would say that kind of [ __ ] but
the truth is I yes I can handle it but I
can also not be alone while I handle it
and that's something that I'm just kind
of grasped and recently um but man my
brain is rattled I'm all over the place
you know I've been on vacation but I
wanted to be here for you guys because I
knew that you guys are here for me and
you were getting I mean it's wild man so
many people are listening these days and
you know so many beautiful people came
out to the show this weekend that just
loved the podcast you know a couple that
was about to move to Houston there were
four or five ladies that all work in an
office together and I loved you know I
thought that was fun man my first job I
ever had
hmm I used to you know the same girl
actually I've told this story before
there was a girl that kind of
masturbated me into a into a creek or
into a you know oh sorry the first hand
that I ever got you know I you know this
girl spray you know give me a [ __ ]
and now I'll just say this girl it
wasn't just like some floozy it was you
know the love of my life at the time but
she [ __ ] to me into this um like
River part of a river but it was like
part of a river where it kind of comes
off to the side like a little just like
a little pond like a bay like a little
like not the main part of the river a
little part where the river kind of
reaches off and doesn't do anything over
there you know like part of the river
that's always rest and kind of off to
the side and like a little hole but
anyway this girl kind of [ __ ] me into
that into that deal and had some fish in
there and the fish swam up and um and
the part what's you know the part of my
body that it sprayed out into the water
the fish snacked on that you know they
ate up all my you know oh my you know
all my adventure sauce or whatever was
inside of my body and what's his story
about today my camera what the story's
about um uh what the [ __ ] was not
talking about I was talking about um
[ __ ] oh oh something about sexual this
um mmm Oh some people that came out to
the show anyway I don't know how I got
in this something but I hinge out but
yeah all types of people came out to the
show you know and it was just you oh oh
oh because I remember this girl that I
dated that girl that [ __ ] me into
that passive area of water her I used to
work at with one of her family members
and they gave me one of my first jobs
and um and I was you know I worked as
like a office clerk and so I be out
there doing clerk office type stuff and
I worked in an office of four or five or
six or seven ladies and a couple of
always had carpal tunnels and a couple
I'm always you know had on a neck brace
or some kind of [ __ ] because we worked
in insurance or something and so
everybody was always faking something at
the same time because they were so close
to insurance then everybody passed on a
neck brace around that [ __ ] like a
joint you know like a big smoking uh you
know that big smoking horse leg full of
that dank Bank and everybody you know
wearing that neck brace and suing this
and getting that and getting him checks
and cutting that money and getting them
chicks and what happened to me was that
I worked over there and I worked in an
office for you know five or six or seven
or eight ladies and there's always
somebody's birthday you know oh it's
Donna's party you know or it's dawn or
it's Margaret you know or um you know
you know you know Sandra's husband you
know got electrocuted because he worked
with The Electric Company and he also
smokes a lot of weed how about this
Sandra's husband don't [ __ ] and do those
things at the same time that's that is
crazy bro you're gonna smoke weed and
then play with electricity oh [ __ ] no
you're not guy that's crazy
so anyhow but I worked over there that
was a place that I worked at and so yeah
we had a lot of neat people that came
out man
you know people drove in they had a
couple that's moving to Houston together
they weren't gonna be able to come see
me in Chicago they drove out some kids
were on LSD they came out and kind of
got scared and they left we had a couple
senior citizens one man said him think
he'd be alive next year to see the show
so he wanted to come out this year I was
like damn bro you know I don't know we
don't offer like a discount on ticket
for that thing you know that death
discount that deaths count like do you
get 40% off you think you're not gonna
be alive next year
markdown tickets 40% off so that was
interesting but yeah it was just good
man and then next thing you know I just
get to be in you know I stayed at this
beautiful little place like it's usually
like a huge rental
all or whatever and got to stay out
there and just a lot of love in the air
man just a lot of love just being around
family and being around just people
relax and enjoying people just looking
at each other eating potato salad
there's something about watching
somebody and there's one man he he got
all kind of peace salad and I called it
peace salad for short instead of saying
potato salad all the time cuz sometimes
I'm in a hurry and he got that pea salad
up in his uh up in his word curtain you
know up in his mustache and he fell
asleep and dude it's kind of you know
I'm not a real you know I'm not a real
pervert you know I'm I've played one and
I'll do that kind of thing but I've
never you know I'm not I don't have any
plan to be anything crazy you know but
uh but at the it's hard to think of that
somebody is and if you see a man fall
asleep and he's got that yellow mustard
in his stache and he just dozed off with
a plastic fork in his hand I mean I
don't want to say it's erotic because
it's not it's just really I mean that's
the dark arts you know when you see a
man with a mustache and he's been just
having some peace outlet some peace
salad and then he just dozes off you
know because he can't handle you know
maybe it's got too much egg in it or too
much uh you know maybe some other kind
of [ __ ] in its in and I don't know what
the [ __ ] him pea salad but he can't
handle it all in so he dozes off you
know his brain shuts down you know he
closes down shop for a little bit and
shuts his eyes and then you see but in
his mustache he still got that yellow
that yellow thick thick just hanging out
hanging out up in his word curtain and
he can't hang and he can't live life and
and that's honestly that's probably a
pervert so but yeah I got to see one of
those this weekend and that's fun that's
family you know this family but look I'm
gonna keep this episode we had some
calls that came in I'm gonna get to some
of those because my brains a little all
over the place and I mean and and and I
want to get it done for you guys I'm
gonna let you know first and
for most that next weekend I'll be in
Oxnard California then I'm in China in
China is a big huge country and all kind
of stuff happens over there and I'm
gonna be one of the things that's
happening over there and some people say
China
some people say China and China is
nothing that's not it's not a real thing
so it's China and I'll be over there
July 12th through the 14th so if you
have any friends over there to live in a
Shanghai or Shimon hit him up tell him
hey go see my friend also coming up I'll
be in Raleigh North Carolina Minneapolis
Chicago Nashville Toronto Appleton
Wisconsin Buffalo Salt Lake City
Washington DC and Minnie oh yeah we
already said Minneapolis Minneapolis
shows almost sold out so we might be
adding to the second show there I don't
know yet but thank you guys for coming
out you're putting a lot of pressure on
me to to keep coming up with new
material and stuff but I'm grateful for
it you know because it makes me feel
more challenged and that makes me feel
you know makes me feel excited you know
it's scary it's scary to know if my
brain will have more ideas you know
that's something that scares me a lot
thinking well am I gonna run out of
ideas you know am I gonna run out of you
know memories am I gonna run out of
memories that are good memories that I
can tell a story about you know it's
alarming I guess it's just like a
painter think you know will what if all
the paint doesn't exist tomorrow what if
they dry up or they shut down a couple
colors you know what a fuchsia or
magenta goes out of business
you know what if Roy's ebf goes under
and then I'm just standing here just
with nothing with nothing on my palate
so yeah it's um it's scary but I guess
that's the excitement it's a little bit
of that fear you know having one foot
out in the fear instead of two instead
of two feet on the dock you know because
I'll say this man and I and I don't mean
to go back this is a little bit perverse
but you know when that when that girl
sprayed me out into that little pond or
whatever it was a part of a river that's
not moving you know what I'm saying
at first I was like man this is
you notice it's kind of its kind of
shady but it's [ __ ] cool you know and
and then I was like then the fish came
over and I was like aha this is scary
this is scary because after that I had
dreams that I had like there were fish
out there that had my face and had the
same kind of chin and cheekbones as me
and all kinds of weird [ __ ] but there
was some there was a moment in there
when it was scary that that's when it
was exciting you know when I don't sit
here in the comfort all the time you
know when I get out into and when I get
out and when I get out into exciting
when I take when I take when I keep some
risk and when I keep a little bit of
risk in the tent and I don't just put
safe gas in there I [ __ ] put a match
up in the top right corner of the tank
and just say hey hey fates hey
powers-that-be let's see how this breaks
down but you can find all the tickets
for all those places Salt Lake City
Washington DC all those places at theof
on calm slash tour ok we had a lot of
calls you can always hit the hotline if
you want to be associated with the
podcast the numbers nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three here you
go
we had a call that came in you know I'd
like to know who is listening to the pot
and and usually I won't get into calls
this week I'll try and you know go
through my own life and my brain a
little bit more but man honestly this
week has just been it's been crazy dude
I shot I worked on some television set
this week but they had a part of it
where it's like a big huge house party
in the Hollywood Hills and so next thing
you know I'm there I'm in the Hollywood
Hills and the guy whose house it was
this beautiful gentleman and he was in
the band called extreme and they had
that song more than
dudes and it was like a you know it was
a kind of song you could you know you
could really feel yourself to or you
could see somebody else's body to it but
um but they had a and part of the scene
they have porno going on people shooting
doing sex by the pool and so next thing
you know they really had that in the
scene I thought was gonna be fake right
I'm involved in the dialogue I'm
supposed to be doing with this other
character I look over and they got
people doing real porno like what y'all
[ __ ] outdoors man there's some real
Native American style is pilgrims you
know that's real pilgrims I just had a
sip of coffee but I'd like to know who's
listening to the podcast and so we got
this call let's go I can do Vaughn I got
to just tell you something man I'm
listening to this podcast and I just
love what you are doing so much I am a
board-certified neuropsychologist I am a
graduate of Harvard Medical School so I
want to let you know two smart [ __ ]
out here you listen doing these s B's
out there cam and I just want to tell
you that every time I hear you talk
about the dark art which is funny as
[ __ ] I'm not gonna lie it's funny until
you just lay it in your house you know
and you don't spray it out all on your
knuckles and you got nothing left in
your heart but I feel you though onward
I want to let you know that what you are
also doing and offering to people is
truly the healing arts even though my
specialty is dementia and helping people
with brain injuries I do a lot of
therapy and just try to connect with
people about trauma and heartbreak and
the way that you talk to people and the
way that you accept people and the love
that you show to people I needed to
reach out and tell you that what you do
is so unbelievably needed and so
therapeutic and you do it so so so well
if you were not a natural-born comedian
and hilarious as [ __ ] as you are I would
absolutely encourage you to go into
social worker well I didn't mean to cut
you off there but I I appreciate the
nice words I yeah it's hard for me to
hear sometimes people say nice stuff
about me
but I really do appreciate it's very
sweet of you Anna you know now I feel
bad about cutting you off because I
wouldn't I'm not really trying to cut
you off here
psychology because you are a natural
what you do for people is not just make
us laugh man what you do is you provide
people with the space of love and
acceptance and self-reflection and
support and I think that so many people
out there can't hear that message unless
it comes from someone who's genuine and
well I appreciate it you know you know
that's nice you to say you know I feel
bad like kind of you know when you say
nice stuff about me it makes me feel let
me think about what I'm gonna say feel
man you got me feeling emotional now but
that's okay I like you know I like
having some emotions you know for so
long in my life I didn't have any I
didn't I had emotions but I'm just anger
and fear and um and probably just like
feeling like not worth you know feeling
not worth you know probably damn he got
me leak and now probably feeling not
worth um not worth love you know and I
didn't know at the time I didn't know
that's what it was I just felt I just
felt angry you know and I just I felt
funny and I felt you know I felt uh I
felt a lot I felt I did not feel alive I
didn't feel comatose or anything like
that I just I felt I guess I felt
unloved you know even though I didn't
realize it and I've never really
accepted compliments very well I don't
think but I think I sweetie you to say
and I you know I feel like I mean it's
crazy to me cuz look if he'd asked me
five years ago if I you know I don't
know if I would have had a lot of the
same feelings inside of me I think a lot
of it for me has come from and I go back
on this stuff sometimes but getting in
like a 12-step program
stuff like that because I couldn't see
that there was so much more in the world
that I was missing emotionally before I
just I felt people would always say I
think I can't get to know you I like
really this would be girlfriends and
everything you know and even dudes that
were jerking off outside of my window
you know I'm a I'm joking about that
part but this would be girl you know be
like hey I just feel like I'm like
really to me everything seems I tell you
everything it seemed like we know each
other but there was this other level
where it was hard to get to and and I
find still though that them you know if
I don't stay on top of what's going on
with me and stay in touch with myself
and and try and stay in touch with other
people that that that part of me creeps
back really fast that's disconnected and
that's very scary to me and that's one
of the biggest fears in my life right
now is um is getting is becoming
disconnected because I've flirt and work
in this disconnected world in a hot in
Hollywood but you know I just try and
stay close to people that I care about
and and not be afraid to care about him
if I can and also look I'm learning as I
go so but I'm happy to know they get
they got some real legit [ __ ] out
there from Harvard Medical Medical
Center who were who were psychologists
or psycho therapist you know it's funny
as I was just thinking this week
actually I wish I could go back to
school if I had more time to go back to
school and and try to learn how to just
be like a more effective listener that's
what I'd like to be like I wish like
when I was listening to somebody if they
if I knew that they weren't feeling good
that I could ask him a question or or
make us you know a suggestion that would
help them you know what helped him feel
better
so I don't know bro I don't mean to get
off on all this [ __ ] you got me off on
all this stuff but thanks for calling
thanks for calling and uh you know I'm
just out here I'm just one of these
people but uh but I'm happy to be here
and I'm happy to be here with you
you know today and I'm happy for all
that this past weekend listeners that
came out to this weekend man it's crazy
we got to find some way to do something
more on weekend shows where we could do
something together and I'll start to
brainstorm what that could be maybe we
got another caller here we go the big
afternoon Association this is nomadic
beastly Oh some long pants and village
calling for the Bronx damn nomadic
beastly on Instagram I'm guessing and
then uh handsome Julius out the Bronx
way handsome Julius came out just
calling to let you know I'm a urban guy
I'm from the inner city the bad boroughs
and like your name probably hasn't said
that often in the Bronx that's probably
true man you know I have sometimes you
know sometimes Julius I wish that I
could live like more than one life you
know and uh and maybe I will maybe we
all will you know if our you know our
higher power wants that for us or if we
handle this life okay enough for if it
was comfortable enough on us and it
wasn't too painful then maybe we'll get
to come back and do it again in some
facet but but but sometimes I think
about whatever we like to grow up on in
New York you know out in the Bronx baby
that Fat Joe country you know out there
Rose Hill you know out there for them
you out there just like walking around
and the sunshine and like just
everything you know they got a dead
pigeon over there and they got people
playing you know bait handball against
the walls and they got Dominicans and
they got you know Puerto Rican people
and they got [ __ ] somebody you know
throwing all that her spouse's clothes
out to a second-story window and and
they got some grandmother just pinching
her kids Italian cheek and they got a
you know they got
just just life they just have so much
life going on and it's faster they're
you know but New York has a New York has
an amazing ability where they have a
little bit of this it's almost like you
get a small town in a moment there New
York there's so much going on you get a
small town in a moment like you can get
a you can get a million years of small
town life almost sometimes in a moment
in New York just turning a corner and
opening your eyes and it's just
everything is so fast but thank you for
calling Julia's home we're brother but
I'm watching and I'm listening all on
the training on my way to work every day
I'm electrician by the way oh hell yeah
dude electrician I was just talking
about electrician if somebody's
electrician man us and they smoking weed
at the same time boy hmmm I mean as I
mean that's the new I mean that you're
basically you're a damn science fair
project if that's what you're doing man
come on and although it's based in humor
and based in like you know driving or
sarcasm but should have been broke I
appreciate all the positive words that a
mass inside the jokes
well thanks Julia sister night as nicely
the same man nice if you think about
that you know but yeah man I just know
that you live in a life that a lot of
people dream about you know that
alternate life just some kind of mob and
around New York with your eyes open
you know just feeling although you know
beautiful women goes by and somebody to
[ __ ] you know deviant vagrants or
whatever [ __ ] beating each other with
prosthetic limbs across the street and
you got you know you know somebody
shooting bullets in the air trying to
catch him in his mouth and you got
everything you know I was in New York
one time some somebody jumped off a
building and killed themselves or
whatever and the crowd starting to
disperse you know and then some lady
walks up and she goes did you see it and
I'm like what was that I'm thinking
about the body or something you know
maybe this and this was on I don't know
she was homeless but she you know like
to pretend she was homeless a lot I
guess and maybe she was pretending
this day that she was she goes did you
see it and I said what and she just
pulled her dress up and showed me that
big that big coochie bra you feel me
show me that big [ __ ] tiger's mouth
she had down there boy that big side you
know that big [ __ ] you know look like
about three or four salamanders sleeping
next to each other and one of them you
know one of them had the gout but ya
crazy man and thanks for calling man you
know like thanks for calling do you seem
like a tough you seem like kind of like
a tougher guy and maybe you know I think
tough got tougher guys always kind of
made me a little bit nervous sometimes
when I was young but here you and I are
communicating so that's cool man it's
pretty cool you know we got some
follow-ups from last week's calls and I
know I'm not getting too deep this
weekend of stuff but but but but those
are some people that listen we got an
electrician we got a bad [ __ ] out of
Harvard Dental or whatever you know
medical dental [ __ ] brain whatever I
need a molar and my cerebellum baby girl
you feel me I need a [ __ ] that mental
floss but we also have some follow-ups
from last week and I want to get to
those because those are important
because it's you guys getting to give
feedback to previous callers onward hey
Daniel Khan from Maui this is in
response to the guy that got asked to
marry got to be married by the [ __ ]
orange chips or whatever yep this is
Daniel from Maui and Maui boy y'all out
there floating out there in the middle
of nowhere eating pineapples dude and
[ __ ] catching salmon in your jaw and
also you just said that this oh yeah we
had a call last week and a boy said um
he said that uh he got propositioned by
a woman to marry him and this is kind of
an older lady and he's considering it so
here's a suggestion from Daniel yeah
don't do it in it's not worth it my my
kids mom
done on that [ __ ] mess and nearly a
friend the friend Peters I don't know
like 20 grand or something barriers
here's I you can slaw being or some [ __ ]
like that well you could slop in just a
regular place but yeah I don't what
you're saying something wild out there
you know I'm saying like Russia but
maybe in the mountains or something
homework and it again and they married
out and I think that chick got [ __ ]
deported no I don't think anybody's
going to go to jail over it but that
[ __ ] ain't worth it man do not pass go
do not collect $200 so look yeah you
could be damaging your future look these
offers come along a lot I think in life
in America where somebody's like hey
marry this person for 20 G they can live
in the country or whatever and I had an
opportunity you know in the past I got
offered a couple of cleaning ladies that
families were trying to keep in the US
and it I didn't go through with them and
everything's been fine so I think you
know I think I'm agree with you on this
dan you'll pass it up man let it go
you know I'm saying maybe maybe a real
woman that you actually are in love with
and maybe one day y'all might get
divorced and she'll just take all your
[ __ ] so that way you know nothing all
right let's hear another call right here
man or you might just fall in love hey
Adam calling from Bellingham dude and I
was a with a friend one time who his car
broke down in Bellingham and I said I
think I saw I remember about it let's go
and listen to your show two weeks now
thought it was pretty funny when
listening to weeks of mail man related
things and guess what your boy Elmo yeah
man why you up there slinging letters
boy you that package savage baby you out
there boy with them perfume samples and
you out there just dropping off them
sweet sense into people's boxes boy
throw
hit of that yesterday louder up into
somebody's dirty box man I love that you
know I was just talking today about how
how crazy it was two male men called
male people male persons whatever you
know I'm saying badass [ __ ]
that's dropping off that uh you know
that um that male and and uh and they
both had dogs barking in the background
I thought that was awesome but thank you
for calling it Adam he's a mailman as
well anymore and I was laughing at the
guy last week who got proposition for
sex mm-hmm out on the street I'm
wondering I've been a mailman two years
and one I guess what I'm wondering is
why not me hmm so you ready for
something and this could be look if
you're a stay-at-home mom stay-at-home
dad you know the here's the thing some
jobs it's already set up you know put
this in the box lick this stamp you know
I'm saying stuff this envelope [ __ ] me
buy this stack of paper you know I'm
saying there's already enough kind of
things out there in that world where you
can easily lead right into sex you know
it is kind of crazy if you when you
think about this and it reminds me of
the movie Bridges of Madison counties
and how you could just be there lonely
for so long or if you are lonesome and
you have a man coming by each day and
yen Hollerin at that man now you might
not be doing it because you're married
and you're in a committed you know and
that's where you're at but sometimes you
remember you just have to change it up
sometimes you got to put a you know you
got to put a foot out into that fear you
something you got a [ __ ] a male person
sometimes you have to [ __ ] a male person
think about that cuz think about this
say you're running around town a small
town or even a city there's dogs chasing
you and the weather is trying to get you
in hail snow hail snail rain tornadoes
rain Eidos weather you've never even
[ __ ] heard of is coming after these
people coming after you imagine you're a
male person
and you doing all of this and all of
that and surviving and finally finally
one day somebody [ __ ] you during the
afternoon how would you feel pretty good
I bet huh you know sometimes you have to
look at it from the other perspective
but thank you for calling Adam maybe
you'll get some man maybe you'll get
some here's one more follow-up from last
week I feel my name is the dahle I live
in Utah thank you for calling Lee doll I
think it's Lee doll or VTOL I can't tell
but I thank you for calling you doll and
I'm married and have a beautiful little
girl oh man you got a beautiful child in
this uh that's awesome and little girls
are so sweet that's perfect
more I was just calling because only to
know that you know what you were saying
really inspired me when it came to that
guy that had lost his grandpa and his
girl ayah recently about a month ago
lost my best friend I'm in the military
used in the military I lost them to
drugs and I lost I also lost my sergeant
and you know it's been tough been rough
I do agree that a drug I was using
himself me feel also as well and I want
to let the guy know that you know even
he's not alone I'm there with him and
you know he won't let him know he's not
alone and I'm trying to quit these drugs
men and I know he probably wants you to
so if there was something we can do we
can both you know we're at the same time
or something I'm not really sure where
I'm going with this
I want to help them out because I don't
want anyone to feel what I feel you man
yeah I feel you dude it's tough when you
know somebody else hurts and you have
had experience with that same pain and
you know they're going through it man
it's like secondhand
smoke but for your heart isn't it it can
be pretty hectic well thanks for calling
man you know what I tried to reach out
this weekend to that gentleman and I'm
gonna try again tomorrow and um and
maybe we can connect you guys see if
he's okay with that and yeah at least
you could you know you'll know you're
not alone then you know it's crazy how
much different it gets when you just put
a little bit of light on me a problem
man because problems they prosper in the
darkness they probably they become
Picasso's in the darkness man just a
little bit of dirty ink and next thing
you know it's [ __ ] Vincent Van Van
Valda Mort you know it you know that and
that's the dark arts things prosper in
the darkness and you got to shine a
little bit of light on a man and it can
lift up a little bra you know I feel
that man I believe that should I know it
sounds crazy dude have you know or what
the [ __ ] does this dude know what he's
talking about
oh well dude you know what I'm saying
I'll smoke a couple bowls of my own dick
son you know I'm saying I'll babysit a
cat with my nuts bro because that's who
I am bruh I'm saying
I'll eat caviar off your cousin's ass
cheeks son cuz I'm rich and naughty
yeah foul man all right let's take a
couple of calls that came in Oh best
weekend worst weekend you know what i'ma
do though AHA let's go hey Theo this is
Haley from rural Illinois hey Haley I'm
in rural Illinois right now onward um
I'm just cleaning somebody's house doing
my thing you know just like every day oh
you a house cleaner you know what I just
realized the other day like I'm okay
with tip and bartenders and servers you
know at a bar if I buy a drink but I
just I weigh whether a tip a house
cleaner you know I'm saying because I
mean I'm doing you know if I'm at a
motel room or hotel room or something
you know what I'm saying I'm leaving
[ __ ] back hair on the mattress you
feel me homework but uh I had the best
weekend ever this last weekend my
boyfriend and I and our three
friends went camping my star grokken we
did some hiking you do draw you know oh
yeah you went hiking up a starved rock
and you know it's so funny I drove past
starved rock today and I was like who
the [ __ ] would ever hang out around
there and bam you just call excuse me
and you just call that's pretty sweet
because it seemed like a place starved
rock I seem like things you know a place
where things didn't end well for
somebody or for a group of people but
I'm glad you guys got out there and had
fun you know I wish that I went camping
more my sister and her kids go camping
all the time and you know I don't do
enough of that kind of stuff I don't
really get connected out there in nature
enough and I need to work more on it I'm
gonna try to make that a goal for myself
let's hear more we did some drinking we
had a great time and to top it all off a
boyfriend and I came home and then we
like kayaking now when I come on over
there we go a little frisky
maybe one third three times it was
really fun but yeah I can't wait to see
you in Wyoming this Friday I'm calling
in tell my boss I got the ship so that I
can come see you
Wow so you already came to the show then
oh this is this is wild this came in
this week well yeah it's crazy 80 called
your boss and say you get the shit's
that's pretty cool that's pretty I mean
that's
nobody can denial or lie about that be
you and your boyfriend got around out
there on that Mackinac River and was out
there spanking and bust and around each
other and I like that you know I
remember being going to band when I was
young and and stopping and doing some
sex and doing some child sex is I was
still a child and so was the girl that I
was singing and we could legally have
sex with each other because we were both
children and doing some child sex out
there on the banks and yeah it's fun you
know what's fun about that kind of stuff
you got to [ __ ] fast because your
friends are waiting for you there right
up around the bend and you slip off on
that sandbar and bust out you know and
it's all I mean ever in your general is
everything's gentle so cold you can't
even tell what's getting [ __ ] or
what's doing the you know what's doing
you know really doing a lot of the
darting and what's doing a lot of the
accepting it's just basically like
smashing
cold meat into it chunks a cold meat
into each other until until both of them
uh you know just come out a little but
thank you for calling that is a best
weekend let's hear another submission
for our best worst weekend hey Kyle from
Maryland I just wanted to call in talk
to you a little bit about my past
weekend my girl almost eight years just
moved in yesterday
ooh brave boy more so all pretty stoked
about that pretty cool uh you know me
Mason nice dinner and in the mid call
that chopping garlic [ __ ] cut my and
girls it they're always happy
everything's neat great day [ __ ] ends
up in the emergency room cuz my hands
ooh
the irony for a vampire huh homework we
end up getting back after you know just
a few stitches and then we put on the
Theo von Netflix special laughing
hysterically go get us you know go get
it done get it in afterwards uh their
bed rolls on she state tell me you know
I feel alone the funny dude funny guys
or we look it up boom you're in
Washington DC in November before that's
a ticket gonna come see you buddy hey
thank you guys man and it obviously I
know I'm not the only person who
realized that that's a threesome
invitation right there you know what I'm
saying a little bit of garlic a little
bit of cutlery trip to the hospital
couple stitches Netflix people [ __ ] I
mean look I mean how much more code or
charades you got to put down there for
no y'all trying to get daddy in that
bedroom that is awesome man and the
crazy thing is if you cut your hand open
and you're having sex so if you almost
have to keep your hand in the air so it
doesn't drop very much but that's
interesting man and I appreciate your
weekend that is a great weekend both of
these are great we got one more
submission for this past month and then
on next week I'll let you know who won
for this month now for our best worst
weekend here we go hey Theo
calling for the best worst weekends good
boy Devin being gunned down oh shut up
my boy Devin be out in Young's TZ boy
Youngstown Ohio and that's a great place
to get a you know you get up get some
cornbread and get [ __ ] up as well and
get mugged maybe even or even you know
you know we're also get into military
onward ah I don't really know if I want
to say some other bad weekend to say but
this weekend I just hung out with my dog
and volley man hung out with your dog
and a little bit of ecstasy huh hmm that
sound like some David in the nomes type
of [ __ ] remember that cartoon David in
the nomes and they had like little
gnomes and suddenly they had a wolf or
like a doll like a sled dog hanging out
with him and you're like damn they got
this big white dog hanging out with this
little you know frisky little little
person this [ __ ] somebody's on
ecstasy homework [ __ ] I know that
sounds weird that pretty sure we
connected I've got a different level oh
I bet you did do I mean I hope it was
all kind of stuff you can talk about at
the church you know long word [ __ ] man
ah okay and there you go man I don't
know is that bestiality or is that just
friendship what is it what did we just
hear guys what did we honestly just hear
I I do not know
let's take another call right here this
was just a regular somebody hitting the
hotline with a thought or a suggestion
the hotline number is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three and if
you want to contribute to the podcast
call and contribute oh there's also a
video fan line you can send video fan
line questions through our live raised
fan line and that link is on the YouTube
page don't forget to subscribe to the
podcast please let's hear hey what's up
feel its jack from Toronto Canada Zach
from Toronto I'll be up there in Toronto
a little bit later this year so get
those passes to jfl Toronto more
so my conundrum is that I'm 29 and I
never had sex with a girl
Wow
dude I got to think about this man
because you're 29 you never had sex huh
Wow because yeah let's hear let's listen
to you we've listened to me enough let's
sorry I interrupted you Zack more you
know and it's not like I'm not a freak
I'm a bear dude you know I'm like six to
like 230 240 bro you sound cute enough
this girl's listening right now who
would probably [ __ ] your bra and a
couple dudes too bro so one way or
another blue we might get you out of
this Jam let's hear more and you know
I've been spending a lot of time just
working on my education I got some
university degrees oh man so I'll tell
you what you are [ __ ] dude you're
[ __ ] the world bro did you get
yourself some uh some diplomas no you
you you know you know I'm saying you
stacking that paper he's stacking that
that you know those frame fillers man
you got a couple hitters more and trying
to get a career off the ground but it's
like I've never had sex with a girl and
I'm and I never really pursued here
Wow so you're well I mean I I mean a Joe
Rogan talks about this thing called the
N cells I think and it's people that
don't have no interest in sex at all I
don't know if that's what you are cos
have to research it a little bit more
and that's just and also you could just
be your own thing but this is super
interesting man I'd love to I'm have to
call you and talk to you on the air
about this but let's finish your call
but I'm starting to think like in
addition just you look and be celibate
forever dude I heard this and if you
don't have sex and you go to heaven bruh
that there's like everybody it's like
you're like a pinata
and they beat you open and um and all
alike the semen and all that confetti or
whatever like you know because semen is
basically just confetti but from like
heaven and it um it all flies out of
your body that people beat you open and
it flies out of your body but it doesn't
hurt it's good you know but it's just
like it's like a celebration it's like a
maypole celebration or something
that are like I guess like Cinco DeMayo
or something more and also my buddy my
buddy even he really likes those [ __ ]
right okay he's out there escorting more
and he even offered to pay for me to
[ __ ] her and I said no cuz I'm not that
kind of [ __ ] but I don't know what do
you think about that you know it's like
29 years old never had sex with a girl I
got my dick sucked once but as a while
ago I don't know what do you think man I
love it
you know this is fascinating to me you
know this super interesting and it's
fascinating to me that you've been
through all you know you're 29 what do
you do you know what you know this is
kind of a crazy week cuz I'm on the road
I'm gonna leave it right there what does
he do you know here he is he's been
through you know he's 29 years old he's
been alive for 29 years he said you know
and he don't have any sex you know he's
never gotten that warm you know that
warm catfish wrapped around his fricking
you know his uh his you know his uh his
his his his body dark you know he's
never gotten to hide that [ __ ] that
meat cane up a net up in that soft sock
so would it you know at this point
because here's another thing your
imagination I'm sure is I wrote does it
even any and it if you've been watching
pornography which I mean I'm assuming
say assuming you have been watching
pornography there's no way your imagine
that something real like that I don't
think it's gonna be able to compete with
that and also escorts on time look man
escorting is a means to an end these are
women are out there working these are
making it you know these are women who
were so a lot of women putting their
their families through putting their
children through kindergarten you know
it's like that's not the that is in it
that's how you get sex I don't think if
that's a demeaning way this is
interesting what does he do he's 29
years old I'll give you a call but I'll
wait and do that on the air because I
think we should talk I'd love to talk to
you in front of it you know so everybody
can be involved as I learn so that
everyone learns at the same time but
yeah man look we'll get into it we'll
get into it you know I'm gonna finish up
my holiday weekend because 4th of July
is coming up I want to say happy 4th of
July to anybody who served for our
country and I also want to say that you
know this is your America this is your
America don't let any don't let your
boss tell you what your America is
supposed to look like don't let you were
don't let you were a celebrity tell you
what your America is supposed to look
like don't let someone who holds a job
over your head tell you what your
America is supposed to look like this is
your America celebrated however you want
this is your America you don't want to
thank all the men and women who have
served who protect our independence you
know so many times they want to say you
know people want to say oh well you know
anybody can come into the America it
doesn't even matter but you know I'd
love to know from some soldiers out
there how do you guys feel about that
you know if you're protecting our
borders or this might be my mindset and
it's totally wrong because I'm not I'm
not doing this but if you're protecting
our borders what do you think the border
should be like you know how do you
manage the idea of America being like a
safe haven for people but at the same
time America being able to take care of
itself
you know what does that look like are
some of these ideas old ideas and some
of these ideas far-fetched
you know I'd loved it if there's any uh
any people who have served out there who
might have some insight into that
because I can have my ideas but I
haven't protected the walls of uh you
know I haven't protected the
at the wall so you know saying the that
I haven't protected our borders I've
never done it you know I don't what is
that in your heart when you choose to
fight for America or if you choose to
defend America if you choose to serve in
the military is that in your heart or is
that or is it just that isn't Matt you
know that's just part of the job I don't
know I'm just I'm intrigued I'm
intrigued but that's like because there
just seems to be a lot of different
viewpoints on it you know I I tend to
believe that that there should be an
organized way for people to come in and
out of our country that's what I believe
because and here's why to me because
I've traveled to I've traveled a lot of
countries maybe 40 50 and there is an
extremely organized way that I have to
go in and out of those places in some
places
want you there you know I and I just I
don't see how you lose with the
organization in fact I see only how you
gain because then if somebody comes here
and they need help you know who they are
and and I think America we need a roll
call anyway we need to know who's here
you know how can you teach a class how
can you work with the class if you learn
knows in the classroom if they got you
know seven or nine students hiding in
that behind the coat rack because
they're afraid to live openly you know
so I think we got to have an organized
way for people to come into the country
that's what I think but I'm happy to be
proven wrong I'm happy to hear a
different suggestion or a different idea
because you know what there's a good
chance I might not know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about
but I love to know from from people that
protect our borders what do they think
or is there even a group or is there
like a popular group thought there or is
it all just everybody has different
opinions and you just don't bring them
up because you know because it's you're
on the job and that sort of thing but
none of the matter none the matter that
whether people share the same ideas on
the on that or not happy fourth of July
to you and hope you spend it hope you
watch a fat uncle [ __ ] mug down a
four or five [ __ ] hot dogs dude you
know because this America manly and we
can enjoy ourselves and hope you listen
to some good music play some Will Smith
you know what I'm saying
play some [ __ ] your dad might even know
a little play some Will Smith and let's
do it we'll get out of here and this is
a this is again this is Alabama by
Bishop gun thank you very much happy
fourth of July thank you for being here
we'll get a more regular episode next
week I'll see you on Thursdays episode
with Jordan B Peterson hit the hotline
if you have questions for him and be
good to yourselves because I bet you
deserve it thank you guys for coming out
this weekend in Wyoming Illinois and and
just making me feel at home even in such
a small place I had a blast
[Music]
she was hotter than the blacktop broke
down at a truck stop she looked about as
loud as a story sheep
since she was a Christian saving souls
and Suhana and the law of the Senate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]